I think this this what uh you um you had
Elise stonic the congresswoman was
talking about and what this entire
hearing was about should have been about
Free Speech campuses have not been good
for free speech in years well so but but
they have been and actually has one of
the worst records you what you heard was
them saying what is completely accurate
under the law it depends on the context
this ising about the codes
ofing
but the codes of conduct must adhere to
the law you have to commit genocide to
be able to condemn genocidal language
like that's a that's a dangerous they've
flipped their whole narrative on Free
Speech overnight so that they can go
after Jews and buy extension white
people right so for years we've all
known they've been horrible on free
speech so she says they haven't been
good on free speech and sunny has the
gall to say yes they have